my name is Michael watts I teach at the
University of California Berkeley where
I've taught for over 25 years I first
went to Nigeria in the early 1970s in
the aftermath of the Biafran Civil War
and I've been going back very regularly
since young Boko in northern Nigeria
refers to young people who are Western
educated literally it means children on
the book but what it really refers to is
people who are seem to be in some way
cosmopolitan closely attached to the
state perhaps even secular and modern in
all sorts of ways they have a whole
series of opponents if you like that
transcend education but are very much
wrapped up with a broader set of issues
that I would describe as the failure of
secular national development the fact
that they see that the Nigerian state is
not protecting Islam that it's corrupt
its morally bankrupt people who claim to
be Muslims are feeding at the great
trough of Nigerian corruption
they've gained force and strength
through military training and perhaps
other sorts of resources from these
global jihadist groups but in my view
they're primarily local in character
Nigeria is paradoxical because over the
last 50 years it's taken in because it
happens to be sitting on large resources
of oil and gas a trillion dollars in
revenues that's fast and yet over that
same period not only has inequality
sharply increased one percent of the
Nigerian population account for 80
percent of that wealth in the northern
states where Boko Haram is most active
current poverty rates are in excess of
80 percent of the population so when I
talk about a catastrophic failure of
development in the face of this oil
wealth it's really quite dramatic and
astonishing
you